it's Monday January 20th you filthy
[ __ ] savages uncle Joey's back no
there's no music today but the song of
the day is megalomania off the [ __ ]
sabotage album you put that on this
morning you'll make you want to jump out
of the window
there ain't no song Baker what's
happening you [ __ ] Savage I'm good
thanks you two are my fans no fan of
yours man i watch some of your stuff and
you're very interesting before the pipe
that were talking about drinking that we
basically yeah both quit your uh
drinking in twelve years ago yeah I like
would snort coke twelve years ago yeah
and you snort it dry
no no alcohol like a psychopath like a
[ __ ] serial killer
big gallon of water yeah cuz in my fat
cocaine addicted mine mm-hmm it was okay
- yeah you gotta stay hydrated that's
the secret
yeah these other people the only reason
why they're getting [ __ ] up I just got
bugs in my face like pickles right I'm
not homeless if I have a briefcase yeah
which was my sick mind looking back at
it I was dumb I'm not didn't you guys
yeah it was like yeah what do you want
from me just write three gallons of
water yeah who else drank three gallons
of water today nobody I used to do [ __ ]
like that - were and makeup rules in my
head yeah and then if I eat sushi the
next one I was healed you're good yeah
like albacore right albacore have like
some cocaine
yeah fighting germs I'm dead serious
with you people you this these are not
jokes
I totally make it make sense to me
really did I was gonna go all you eat
sushi and I would drink a bottle of that
[ __ ] red juice right when it was
pomegranate pomegranate right I would
drink a gallon which is like eat the
[ __ ] sugar change Patrick yeah and I
swear to God
like God healed me yeah I go out get
smashed and then go home and if I drank
a whole Pedialyte you know the baby the
infant thing with electrolytes I'd be
like I'm fine like if I because I'd wake
up without a hangover so if you wake up
without a hangover whatever you did the
night before doesn't count
hey that's like how I in my brain I
thought that was fine
no the Attic the mind works how do you
feel now that you have you don't smoke
dope I don't I don't smell never smoke
dope I did I used to smoke weed but that
I think I quit smoking weed just cuz
like I wasn't getting as much done as I
wanted to and that was like smoke
quitting smoking weed was so [ __ ]
easy it's like the withdrawal is just
boredom and that's it so if you can deal
with being bored you're fine you know
you're from DC originally mm-hmm you
went to Emerson College you're usually a
[ __ ] goombazz alumni yep we sat here
you two young kids broke my heart by
saying that you thought it was a waste
to go to [ __ ] college
yeah it is a waste you know if you're in
entertainment it's a [ __ ] waste
especially art school yeah yeah now look
at it from a guy like my perspective
like I came from Cuba you know what it
would be like to go to an American
College like that was like my parents my
mother's dream like yeah I meet a girl I
got notre-dame and [ __ ] and Rara and
paint your face and and then you go when
you go through this hole because when
you look at it in hindsight it's like
this brainwashing right cuz I think you
guys get it when your third your third
year of college and you're like what the
[ __ ] am i doing yeah yeah
now that you've picked your major yeah
got thinking you start double-checking
yourself mm-hmm and that [ __ ] with you
yeah [ __ ] with you because your friend
Susie who's a dumb [ __ ] her father beat
her with a whip they hit him in the head
with a brick
she had a quit school cuz he got
pregnant she was 18 right she's working
out the stock market driving him to say
these bands yeah she hasn't sucked the
[ __ ] and a buzz kill me you know I mean
so you start
I don't know in your mind there's a
college this is why just this whole
thing kills me about college and I've
been this upset such a scam Lee was the
one who really I call me let me imagine
when you go to these interviews do
people even bring up everything like
like if you walked into it like if I was
a Hollywood mogul me being me Joey Diaz
somebody who started like as an
assistant to somebody yeah and I scare
myself into VP of Operations right then
I became like if I interview you for a
job I'd be like mesmerized like so you
went to Emerson College oh my god like
to me was so prestigious yeah you know I
heard of Emerson camp you know but ever
since for entertainment yeah right
there the only goal for me the only time
I ever got asked was probably like the
first job like the first job out of
college only gonna intern right like did
you go to college right and you're like
yes check everything out everything else
after that all they care about is your
experience yeah and college
well for me I should have if I was smart
I would have gone to like even
University of Colorado and done computer
stuff then I'd like that something
worthwhile yeah going art school and I
was lucky like I was sure I knew I want
what I wanted to do I had people who
graduated from Emerson and then went and
had to do like another year somewhere
because they they said oh I wanna go to
law school instead yeah and they just
grinned to get a film degree that
they'll never ever even think I have a
friend from Emerson that was in costume
design and it took her six years and
then she realized she wanted to be a
physical trainer and then she had to go
to a whole other thing it was like Jesus
Christ you know like and it's and now
she's just I think she just bought a
house finally but it's like you can't do
anything with the I mean and even for me
I would just go I was going on auditions
and [ __ ] so they didn't even care that I
went to college they were like oh you
have no experience whatsoever like in
the real world it doesn't count like
your play that you did in college
doesn't count you it I should have just
[ __ ] move to LA
all do you understand that I was 27
okay so you were not were you thinking
stand up but I'm listen no not at all it
was the farthest thing I didn't even
want to do stand up when I started it
like I was just kind of I just had a bad
year and I and I was lost and I was like
maybe I'm gonna be a dog trainer or I'll
be like a social worker and my friend
was like you would suck at both of those
things you're not a warm person you you
don't have the personality for that so
just go and do like try doing jokes cuz
you're always sending them to me just go
try to do stand-up and I tried it and
I'm an addict so I got a laugh and then
I kept going I kept going every night I
just gotten out of this relationship
with a guy that was pretty physically
abusive like it was a domestic abuse
situation and I was just like he was an
actor and I was like I want nothing to
do with the acting world I don't want to
[ __ ] even look at a headshot ever
again
and stand up just became kind of a way
to talk about the [ __ ] that was
happening
did you act in high school uh yeah
because I didn't get along with mr.
Pohlman trust me I was on Facebook -
suck my dick it was fifteen credits and
there was stage handing yeah no way you
built with two stages of [ __ ] yeah
right so his name was Bob Pullman and in
high school speaking of allegations
because this is how we to us yeah he
used to get weed shipped in from Hawaii
$5 for a [ __ ] April tie stick it was
like a stick with lead tied around it
yeah and he didn't like me so he never
let me but then my freshman year I took
intro to Performing Arts what some
stupid [ __ ] thing like that like it
was a quarter of doing each yeah I don't
never forget I had a lesbian teacher who
I really liked
she was chubby the whole lesbian how he
was a chump it was tough being lesbian
in the seventies wasn't easy yeah and
she said something to me when they she
goes I want you to do it was improv yeah
because I want you to do
lip-sync a song like what because I want
you to lip-sync a song and I go you know
what it was the weirdest thing like a
she somebody had you ever talked in the
sixth grade the teacher told me if I
behave on Fridays he let me sing in
front of the class yeah so I was very
well on Fridays I would go up there put
Frankie Valli uh yeah every Friday at
one o'clock we would break up into
groups we have kool-aid [ __ ] you don't
get sugared up and stuff we [ __ ] sing
turn on the old tunes
yeah I'd sing Frankie Valli songs his
name was mr. Levine oh so when you
actually know what he loves like him
lip-sync him to sing about the same I
could sing I was in a band then my voice
changed everything third the hell how
did it change this much cigarette
swallowed a chainsaw oh yeah it was just
weird because I wanted that memory to go
away yeah so that was seventh grade then
I got left back in the seventh grade and
by the eighth grade
nobody really remembered so for freshmen
here to somebody just to drop it on me
like god damn it the workout oh yeah how
people gonna make me karaoke that that
was probably the beginning of karaoke so
I'll never forget I went up there and
did I got on stage and I did shattered
mm-hmm by the Rolling Stones that I
brought the [ __ ] place yeah like the
whole class yeah go crazy and the word
got out that's a certainty nobody meant
nobody made me do it again or anything
like that that's not the point but she
was like somewhere along the line I see
entertainment for you that was like are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] stupid that was
just a joke yeah yeah so did you want to
be a comment no no no that was a fan of
Richard Pryor right like all in on those
three out yeah was it something I said
Bicentennial I was always oh yeah so
that's not how was me but you acting
already a deficit yeah but I
was always a fan of comedy like I used
to watch insomniac every night every
[ __ ] night how good was that show God
it was great with the original Anthony
Bourdain show really yeah no it was
insomniac was the blueprint yeah you
know but [ __ ] day we had to stop
drinking [ __ ] quitter the thing like
for me though was like I don't know
about you guys but at 18 like I was sure
what I wanted to do mm-hmm
like I was sure of it and and looking
now looking back at 18 yet like now
looking at a 18 year old I can't believe
we trust them yeah well yeah I felt so
adult at 18 and now now I feel honestly
now I feel less like an adult yeah it's
weird I don't know I look at an 18 year
old and I'm like yeah you you got it
it's all on you like it's a I feel like
they're fine I don't know they seem like
adults to me but maybe that's just
because I I don't know yeah I'm just
like no listen I'm not saying they have
fully developed brains or anything but
they're not an adult's problem I'm
putting an 18 year old is down but I'm
thinking about me being 18 like I'm
thinking about well the things I did at
18 I didn't make I think a good decision
no no they're not going everything was
bad everything was bad because I thought
I knew everything yeah but they're not
old they're not like young enough to
where their mistakes are an adult's
problem anymore you know like if an 18
year old [ __ ] up that's their [ __ ] up
they can deal with it that's what I mean
yeah but an 18 a coked-up Jody as we're
looking in the eye and say know how to
become an astronaut I had no idea how to
do any of those things at that age thank
God you figured it out damn what I
wanted I owed money I left I went to
Colorado and there yeah I always was not
against but even now I'm like maybe
actually gonna take three credits a
semester yeah go to Valley I've been on
I've been fighting with this of myself
for years
with the baby in term I just really
don't have a night I looked up the
schedule you gotta go like three nights
a week yeah yeah yeah doing online
that's that's not a local Joey yeah I
want to be in the setting I want with
other people I want people to ask
questions that I didn't [ __ ] ask why
didn't I come up with that question
right it's a class setting if that was
one night a week it's like acting class
yeah yeah I guess what Rose but I love
you that I don't want to have to [ __ ]
me you want a Tuesday at 4:00 yeah
rehearse I Love Lucy you know that [ __ ]
used to kill me yeah and once I started
working like once I started working
going to acting class yeah and yeah come
on this is oh yeah there's we're just
doing a [ __ ] fade right from the [ __ ]
this isn't actually Gone with the Wind
we don't actually have to be acting like
this all the time that's the thing I
feel like that's why I wanted to get
away from that world is like those
people actors or they don't know that
the real nobody talks like them nobody
it's not always a scene not everything
is so like but it's our baby you know
like the way that they talk is it's like
it's written you know I'm saying it you
know this whole thing with the Oscars
you really got to think about those how
strong those words out with that Ricky
Gervais is oh my god yeah yes yeah it
was a joke to us but America but he
really did yeah say what do you want to
say and he goes get your little things
and get the [ __ ] off the stage yeah
no disrespect anybody I've worked with
I've done a bunch of movies I'm happy I
got in them I'm very fortunate yeah but
the actor is a different animal yeah the
stand-up comic yeah and was so different
but so far apart way I feel the actor I
did a movie were an actor push the
envelope on everything mm-hmm he was one
of the main actors yeah whatever
tell my shine within this was years yeah
so we're thinking about him now how
[ __ ] much of a dick he was yeah it
was like he did things to piss people
off
little things but then he came off as
the hahahaha garlic right sweetheart
type of guy yeah and he retained the
[ __ ] out of me yeah the main thing that
bothered me about him is that he did
something I can't you're gonna dig into
it he was just a [ __ ] he had done
something and if anybody knows anything
about that heat when you talk to him you
felt like he had done it for 30 years
leave a superstar he did it four times
and they got cut and that was the end of
his career yeah and then he became an
actor and it was just so weird that what
stand-ups we live out that I live that
out by going onstage and saying what the
[ __ ] I want to say yeah I'm not waiting
for your [ __ ] lines on a piece of
paper right I gotta act them out it's
like when an actor becomes a boxer yeah
that's when your mind Macross his
reality [ __ ] well really because I
threw two punches on a guy in a movie
now I'm gonna start training and I hate
to go to just unfortunate gym Hollywood
he used to throw actors out yeah all the
time it was hilarious
yeah and the basses and they would go
you don't want put me in the ring yeah
get some killer I'm gonna transition the
jail for killing this baby's mama mm-hmm
and he's out on parole so now he's got a
missing shoe yeah look that guy Justin
would put him up against guys like that
like oh yeah yeah you're a tough guy on
CSI all right beautiful it was
particularly CSI he was an actor a New
York CSI yeah go there every morning
complete dick yeah parked his [ __ ]
car where he didn't have to park it
always went in had to have his own space
you know had the expensive gear on just
a trash bag
and me and this guy would be in the
corner and I was like 400 pounds
I just been hit in the back that's when
I first started working out yeah and he
would come in there and hit mitts and
the trainer he had had him [ __ ] like
we just wanted don't because that's how
that those trainers get paid right we
should do a special aspiring I know it's
only the only charge of 409 one that I
used to hear right those guys right once
they know you're an actor and they tap
into that you want to be all you want to
be a tough guy all right I'll have you
stabbed and [ __ ] Mickey Rourke and
Stallone it right and every actor
believes you have no idea like that guys
this is why this is a complete different
world than what the [ __ ] you were
illusion it's so completely weird I saw
one guy in particularly CSI New York I
think he was one of those guys that
checked blood on the show yeah it wasn't
the star I saw him go in there every day
jump rope yeah you know I yell at people
he had all he would have a personal
assistant with him who would like rub
him down with towels watering [ __ ] you
know these guys make it not a drop of
blood on him he doesn't even need a
towel Justin personally I saw three
actors get beat them so bad they picked
up the bag of never coming home I'm
researching a role I just might get
another source Yeah right
they had to no no no these are guys that
at one part in their TV career or movie
they had to be a tough guy and they go
well let me back it up now so I'm you
know I'm like it's kind of yeah they
thought they were a them when you listen
I know who's working out it's like when
you see a girl at a gym yeah you know
who's there for dick yeah you know who's
there to get in shape right yeah there's
the girl that's full makeup on right
earphones yeah it's right in yoga pants
it's a monkey on a fire it's coming
through the pants and I did like the
I yeah look at that phone and you want
to go up to listen either suck a dick
your waist and son is a fat [ __ ]
somewhere die Nevada yeah yeah you're
gonna give a guy on the treadmill an
actual heart attack just looking at you
on the body acting a nemesis so once you
and this guy broke up you said [ __ ]
after yeah and this isn't like listen I
still talk to this guy if this was a
relationship where it was like you know
it was when it was over it was like two
boxers that were too exhausted to keep
fighting you know what I mean
so and you know he's not I don't know
how he's doing now we have the original
long time but he's he's like he's a sad
person I don't my heart goes out to him
you know but like I when it was over I
was just like I gotta I gotta get out of
this world like I don't like these
people I don't like and he was a [ __ ]
actor who was a boxer and like yeah just
complete like delusional and I I just
decided like [ __ ] this I can't do this
anymore I started doing comedy I was
like this is the kind of Boston in New
York I started in New York and I am I
loved it like I loved the whole world of
it I liked I didn't even know how
miserable I should have been because
that's how much I liked it because I was
out there I remember it was like the
polar vortex and I was out there barking
every night to do shows at the lantern
and then went from the lantern to lol
which is basically the ha and the ha if
you don't know is like it was like a
real shitty scam for people in Times
Square like people would be walking by
and other people would be like hey Chris
rocks on stage and they go up to this
room and they'd get charged eight bucks
for like tap water and then I'd come out
you know so like the audience's hated me
and I and the relationship was
antagonistic from the beginning so now
as a comic I I kind of that's like how I
came up so that's sort of my
relationship to the audience a little
bit
like I'm ready for like when somebody
throws something or somebody flips out
on stage my heart soars like it's like
that's my favorite thing is when [ __ ]
goes off the rails and there was
something about that that felt like live
theater because it was so but it was
more raw than that because it was a real
thing that was happening and we were all
in it together you know like the
audience is as much a part of the show
as the comic and it's a relationship you
know so there were things from acting
that I could incorporate into stand-up
but it was all my words it was what I
wanted to talk about I could get up
whenever I wanted nobody had to give me
permission I could just [ __ ] go and
do it so I just did it every night for
two years I think I went on stage every
single night and I just and Here I am
it's like it's been six years so and
then see you also did a lot of theater
in college yeah I did do you miss it
yeah I do a little bit you ever think
like maybe I do it off off off Broadway
play I wouldn't you know I would do and
I would do a Broadway play but I
wouldn't do a [ __ ] you know it's like
I look at it now and I go I would love
to do that again if it was if I was
given like a script that was by one of
my favorite [ __ ] writers you know
like Edward Albee or David Mamet or so
you know like if there was a play of
theirs on stage I would absolutely do
that [ __ ] but the problem with acting is
there's just not that there's not that
much out there that's really good and
that was my problem I was like I want to
make something myself and I don't know
that any of my [ __ ] is gonna be better
than this but I know that it'll be mine
so if I'm if I'm tanking it's my fault
you know again something I'm really
jealous of is theater like that's
another thing that I always wanted to
have a tentacle yeah that was another
one of my little pet peeves yeah I got
into a play here I finally something
came up and the pieces fell together
yeah if some guy approached me at the
store and we did a couple rehearsals and
we the table read them they didn't get
the financing so I kind of broke my
heart
yeah it was a dumb [ __ ] play anyway
and then I did a play that was pretty
decent I got I auditioned for it and
booked it mm-hmm they want to rehearse
every [ __ ] day yeah and once we
started doing performances performances
were Wednesday through Sunday yeah
Sunday matinee which I can't [ __ ]
even think of doing because who the [ __ ]
go into a dark Theater on a Sunday at
2:00 right in that way yeah I can see
New York in the winter yeah when it's
[ __ ] gloomy Gus outside yeah but here
and will it stay 80 degrees oh you're
not gonna believe what we're doing today
especially when you can make that money
the money that you'd make in a week of
rehearsals for a show you'd make in one
night on the road like the money
well I found that the work that went
into a play I was like no yeah that's
never gonna happen then they actually
approached me with a play from Lincoln
Center right the guy saw me in the movie
he was your perfect yeah from one of the
passengers let me connect you to my
assistant this one on it I was headed to
New York but it was kind of a musical
yeah and I was 300 pounds that is no hug
that I could move yeah I wouldn't have
to dance a lot it was like one or two
scenes I had yeah they told me the
rehearsal schedule yeah hello and it was
the dead of the winter like I was gonna
be doing all this in February in New
York I know in February it's a wasteland
and now I see it I like I loved like I
right now as we speak I'm working on a
one-man show mm-hmm I've always loved
that yeah always that's great that's why
I oh where are you gonna do it do you
know right now I'm just working hard the
store right three more [ __ ] workouts
left nothing I even put two hours
together yeah it'd have to be two hours
or less right and then my hope would be
to put it somewhere in town somewhere
cute nice maybe a dynamite see that yeah
like sweet sweet three-week run yeah you
know yeah on it and then take a dog
off-broadway off-off-broadway
yeah take you to off Broadway
off-broadway again yeah do a three or
four week run add some final adjustments
find a good director right I would I
would [ __ ] give this shot hell yeah
yeah I really know what I what scenes I
want what settings I want to sell yeah I
wanna a thing with a microphone yeah and
I just want like a street corner yeah
those are the three settings and I would
just shine the light yeah each area I
could go back and forth in between
settings yeah cuz you got it I mean it's
about your life I'm assuming yeah yeah
she's baack just [ __ ] hustle the life
you know what how I even you know look
at how you how the [ __ ] did you [ __ ] do
we stumble upon this yard right I don't
[ __ ] we stumble I always feel like
there's there has to be a lot of you
know not that I regret anything I've
ever done but there's got to be a lot of
mistakes to get you into comedy you have
to make a lot of a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that has to happen something something
is off you know with with comics that
I've noticed in a in a beautiful way
like I I I trust a comic if I meet
somebody across you know if I'm overseas
and I meet somebody in there a comic
there's something automatically that I
just I can there's an ease I can
communicate [ __ ] to them that I wouldn't
say to anybody else it's like it's like
meeting another drug addict or like
another alcoholic or something you know
there's something there like we've been
through it together even if I've never
met them before I feel the same way
sometimes it's I've always known one
thing listen what a person wants to
think of what we do mm-hmm like you this
whole thing started me when somebody
brought up the Joker
yeah it all started with that whole joke
they saw the joke yep I thought about
[ __ ] the early years of comedy your
career yeah that for now it's
abusive relationship right one-way
relationship well it's just abusive and
what what you know you were involved in
the abusive relationship what does it
take to say that's it yeah you know for
this four or five years three years for
some people police don't know long they
just don't know long and then when did
they get it they catch on they want to
grass you know what for some people it
takes 11 months and for some people it
takes five or six years yeah for me it
took three and a half years to finally
go all this is what needs to be done
right this is how it needs and how old
were you when you started when I first
got on stage I was 28 years old
yes so you were older - I was old I was
28 when I first got on stage it took me
a good honest 14 months of
procrastination yeah 14 months of
procrastination yeah before you got on
again oh no like let's go I'm gonna
become a stand-up yeah I'd set up an
open mic yeah and I'd cancel that night
at 6 o'clock yes man it was just this
[ __ ] you know yeah I cried the first
time before I went and did my first mic
I cried outside and was like called up a
friend who was a stand-up and I was like
I can't do it but he was like all right
don't do it you knows like but then I'll
never do it I almost wanted him to talk
me into it and then I realized he wasn't
going to and I was like oh I just want
to do this I'll just shut up and go
inside but like yeah it's hard that
first the realizations yeah you know and
for me now like with this one-man show
what the final message is that I'm
trying to bring is that I didn't become
a comic comedy made me a man mmm it
really made me a man it really made me a
[ __ ] man it made me see a lot of
things you know and let me see
vulnerabilities and people yeah
vulnerabilities and
calmly what we do in the beginning that
we think back that I shouldn't [ __ ]
slap on the her right all those things
yeah this thing has been a journey
Sunday yeah and I want to explain the
journey to people as best of like but I
ain't got enough time yeah this journey
has been tremendous yeah twenty eight
years has been tremendous you know I
told we were driving back last night and
Fresno and miss you came out from the
Rolling Stones mm-hmm and I told George
Perez who I was working with this came
out of a set when I was in the eighth
grade
yeah this was the song over the summer
of the eighth grade in 1978 what I think
that in 2020 yeah I'd be driving home
from a theater in Fresno right look yeah
yeah also humanly came on don't you want
me baby brightness and I was like crying
38 years old yeah if I would have known
that summer of 82 that I'd be in a
[ __ ] doing state I had no idea yeah
this is why this is shocking to me and
obviously near did you yeah and
obviously in a way neither did Lee why
we just we started out Lee want to be a
[ __ ] editor we went to school he's
going to be an editor you went to major
in theater yeah what were your plans
really from there to move to New York
and do to do theater compete yeah Jesus
yeah
and moved to I moved to New York I was
like I'm gonna be a theatre actor that's
what I want and like I did an
off-broadway I did a couple opera yeah
off-broadway plays a bunch of off
off-broadway plays I did some
independent films and I just like I look
back at it now I'm like that [ __ ] was
ridiculous it was like for the birds I
mean once I did comedy I've never been
obsessed with anything like this in my
life you fall in love with it yeah
what's it like the heroine for you a
hundred percent I hid it from my family
how many years did you do comedy before
you quit drinking I know I quit drinking
before I started comedy thank God yeah
welcome well yeah thank you okay so no
because I
wouldn't have been able to [ __ ] quit
if I was doing comedy I don't think I
genuinely don't think how do you you go
to meetings and stuff yeah yeah so when
you walk into a bar any problem when you
see a [ __ ] it's been so long now it's
like when I go to meetings it's really
more for just so I don't act like an
[ __ ] like I don't when I see a drink
I don't like I don't want to drink I
don't Knight forget other people are
drinking I don't like it's not like a
part of my radar you know so it doesn't
bother me at all I just like it's just
not part of my life anymore so you did
all these you've done six years economy
in New York mm-hmm and now you're out
here bill put on his show ringers I'm
starting a podcast the teaser drops
tomorrow February
sorry January 20th and it's called
devil's advocate with rosebud Baker and
it's basically like interviews with
other comics about what's funny about
like the worst things that happened to
us because I always find my humor is a
little dark or people say it's dark I
don't see it that way but people say
it's dark and but I think the dark
things are funny and I think they're
part of what make us funny so it's
really kind of answering that question
you know and and then at the end of
every episode we give a bunch of bad
advice to listeners bad advice
bad advice cuz one eye one thing that
annoys me about the internet now is
everyone's a [ __ ] pro everyone's a
life coach you know and it's like who
the [ __ ] wanted what you've got like who
who said they want what you have it's
crazy you know or prove you have what
you say you know yeah like I just look
at these people like if you think that
you're like in a position to tell other
people what to do you're you're [ __ ]
delusional check I follow just yeah
follow probably 20 people just cuz you
hate them no they're just illusion yeah
they make you laugh they make me laugh
plus I don't want to do what they're
doing yeah I know whatever the [ __ ] that
doing is completely wrong
so thank you for being an example today
thank you for being exactly the wrong
thing you really do it with the wrong
things yeah why would I [ __ ] in the well
do you want into that Joey what's that
you're very positive online and I I
don't put you in that category but there
are people were like oh you got a hustle
saying it kind of it just rubs me the
wrong way you for whatever reason you
found a way to do it without rubbing
people look the wrong way because I
explained it first of all when I write
those things in the morning that's
exactly what I'm thinking yeah it feels
like you're almost talking to yourself I
am [ __ ] you know and I know and I
know for a number-one I'm very lazy by
nature if it was up to me tail
I would stay on that couch all day yeah
my dream job my joy if I could stay on
the couch and not get fat yeah and eat
like everything Tom and Jerry's New York
super fudge chunk Wonka : and watch like
old honeymooners and I would just go
through a series like I'm the type of
guy that would just go the soprano sons
of anarchy oh my god yeah Sopranos i
watch The Sopranos v yeah it's around
and around the road yeah I have things I
you Chinese food every day yeah a
certain restaurant New York I could do
that I do mozzarella sticks like a mom
yeah I'm one of those people I could do
the same [ __ ] over and over and over in
a controlled setting
yeah and be very happy if I don't have
to spread myself right my mother died at
a young age mmm no at 16 so oh wow I
threw a pity party like everybody else
does yeah we lose a relative and then
you add drugs that yeah you had drugs so
that pity party that pity party lasts
forever and it you really take you down
yeah it's a really bad my sister died
when I was 17
very sad so it was like yeah you start
to it's a pretty party yes a [ __ ]
pity party then we create our own pity
party and it's actually
to get to the point where like Haley how
you doing rosebud if you don't rosebud
lost his sister at 17 yeah yeah I saw
myself doing that you know what
here it is plain and simple so your
[ __ ] mother died yeah I'm sorry
yeah I'm sorry she died the world is
sorry but at the same time right this is
not gonna work
this is not acceptable well you know you
sit there and cuz this is what I'll do
in my mind I'll sit there and cry I'm a
crier yeah I won't tear up I watch TV
when I was when I was 18 of 19 and 27
then I got locked up and I came out I
was 30 there was things nobody wants to
do right yeah yeah oh nothing
I don't want to do it but then you have
to force yourself to do it yeah you
learn how to I feel like when you go
through death at a young age there's
something about it that makes you it
teaches you how to parent yourself
because you you grow so much so fast
like within a day like you got the day
before your sister's there your mom's
there the next day they're gone you're
ten years older like right away well let
you appreciate the day and more it makes
you be a better person to people because
you don't know if that's the last time
you ever see them again
right when I see somebody I can't say
that I'm a better person to people but I
try to be you know it gave me all those
insecurities of but it also I'm second
time and hearing excuses jack yeah and
I'm the type of guy before you excuse
comes out I'll tell you why you're wrong
yeah what you know I want I want you to
understand how [ __ ] fortunate you are
right you know it's like that comment
that says to you [ __ ] I got an audition
tomorrow at 11:30 but I go to a water
clock spot at the comedy what's the hot
Club in New York the seller the seller
yeah you want a snack that comment write
some additional loves it go is your
crown too heavy
and guess who said that to themselves
and watch you're tired yeah yeah saying
I got a one o'clock at the [ __ ] store
which means 1:30 and I gotta get up at
11 and be prepared for an audition what
the [ __ ] yeah what the [ __ ] you're doing
spots at the world-famous Comedy Store
yeah yeah yeah there are people that'll
cut a finger off right comics I don't
kind of pinky off there are women that
would suck your dick to do a spot at the
Comedy Store at 1:00 in the morning yeah
what are you crying about and I think
that we that was just the strongest
weapon for comedy rest of my life I
would have to like beat myself up in the
morning like when I was 21 I had a job
at a hardware store delivering plumbing
supplies yeah
7:30 in the morning the things that
would have to tell myself in the shower
right would be frightening for me to get
motivated yeah there's nothing nice no
it's like you just hate yourself into
action you know wait you're so the
[ __ ] yeah like you know warning you
nobody's gonna give you a [ __ ] right
your mother's dead you got dick you got
dick Tony asked now get up right do
something about it go take that dick out
of your ass I had that's how I have to
that's how you thought yeah I I thought
about I was like I remember I was in
therapy and I was like bitching about my
childhood and my therapist said to me
he's like hey you know um childhood was
a game and you lost that's it you don't
get to play again you're an adult now
that's it just go on and I remember
hearing him say that [ __ ] changed my
life like I think about that all the
time when I hear adults talk about and
like it's funny like if we look at the
reasons why we do things now and like
how they correlate to our childhood as
long as we're not blaming our childhood
you know because I think you got a you
got to kind of understand why those
experiences shaped you but you can't use
them as an excuse absolutely like it's
not
you're a [ __ ] adult this is a new
game you got you got to start over you
didn't beat the boss but you were given
a new level anyway so just [ __ ] take
it like see what you're gonna do with
this one
you know I think that when we become
comics who you have to realize when you
become a real comic you to do what we do
I assume the wiring isn't right
somewhere hmm not that we're gonna kill
somebody you're strapped a bomb on
ourselves
you know someone along the line you know
like comics have told me there's two
million doctors
there's 150,000 comedians right you know
nobody drives up to what open mic in a
Bentley Yeah right
it's something that somewhere along the
line you just and I see the drop off
rate but you see that you know yeah I
can't I've been here 23 years 23
February 19th I can't tell you how many
stars I'm seeing common gonna yeah stars
there was comedy stars right come on
they're selling real estate they moved
back this is nada yeah and they're
happier I'm happy what I'm doing because
there was either this is slinging coke
in New York yeah one of my two options I
wasn't gonna have a date
right I was never gonna happen yeah I
have a little my job no they want to
work in a bar then when it gets out I
was no tough guy I didn't want to be a
door guy and get beat up that's it
yeah be the door guys like being a woman
that marches it gets you nowhere
right yes you know where you can watch
the bench
yeah so you would know probably six
years now yeah things popping for about
a year and a half ago
well I started I did this documentary
that Amazon Prime or yeah Amazon video
produced
it's called inside jokes and it was
about comics trying to get into jfl so
there were like six of us we were all
auditioning and it went from callbacks
to the auditions to get all of it to the
festival and there was some that didn't
get picked there was some that did and I
was one of the ones that was fortunate
to go to Montreal and to do new faces
and then when that when that dropped it
was I guess November of 2018 and I while
I was at new faces I got my manager at
levity and ever since then things that
kind of like slowly started picking up I
got the Comedy Central digital thing I
got Bill burr Bill Birds the ringers and
then I got a thing coming out later this
year that Will Smith produced so and you
know my podcasts now my own podcast it's
like things are just starting to like a
podcast somebody else before uh-huh
Corrine Fisher okay
she has the guys we [ __ ] podcast and
then we had our our podcast was called
two less lonely girls it was about
celebrity stalking we stalked Justin
Bieber and we found him and we like we
found his girlfriend's house and we like
interviewed people standing outside of
his girlfriend's house it was about like
celebrity worship and pop culture and
had this kind of like dark twist to it
so and we just put that on hiatus we
might go back to it I'm not really sure
no talk to Justin Bieber yeah I did I
got to talk to him yeah it's all on my
Instagram like the whole like me hearing
where he was and then going to chase him
down and then I followed him for like
three miles and like he was who's before
he got married to hailey and what you is
this
it was mm I guess it was 2017 what was
he around here he lives here okay cuz
then Canada there was a time when he was
always into a factory yeah cheering
somebody out Chris D'Elia
Chris D'Elia it's the lead yeah that's
his favorite comic
yeah then I saw him one time maybe as I
was getting to the economy started an
explosion on sunsets
he's one of his [ __ ] bat cars yeah
cuz he just can't have like his cars are
constantly breaking down he loves cars
he doesn't know anything about them
he's he gets the most expensive cars and
then they're breaking down somewhere
this thing went like by the time yes
they made like it like well he call that
when the muffler shoots back oh [ __ ] it
back by yeah but he took off like he
missed a gear yeah and somebody goes
that was just a baby just miss Justin
Bieber I'm like I never see that
[ __ ] got no way everybody seen
him I that was it I just heard about him
driving around yeah yeah he's not a
great driver but he loves [ __ ] he
loves his cars he just doesn't know what
about them and he says that he's like I
don't know about them but I just I
really like he just walks into her he
just walks into a place and buys a
[ __ ] yeah he's [ __ ] billionaire
how crazy is that it's nuts it's nuts
I but I really like him I don't know
what I am like a fan of his there's
something about him he's a music good
yeah like his music I mean he had
purpose came out like two three years
ago I don't know how many years ago but
um purpose came out that was a [ __ ]
great album but it annoyed me because
that was when people started being like
wow he's really good and I was like no
he's been good he's been good since he
was a [ __ ] 8 year old you know like
he was a yeah he started in Canada oh
yeah he was on [ __ ] YouTube uh sure
found him and Scooter Braun and then he
he like just [ __ ] catapulted to fame
he was just a kid that was playing
guitar on like the sidewalks I don't
know nothing I know Justin Bieber
I know chicks running after him yeah I
know he was on the 101 then did he do
drugs and go off the deep end a few
weeks yeah yeah even Demi Lovato we're
[ __ ] yeah exchanging texts [ __ ] for
sure you know this was a manager now
is that what baby without the word evil
the whole podcast just buzz Justin
Bieber it was Justin Bieber centered
let's do the next one has to be just
let's just bust [ __ ] have Iqbal was
balls yeah like that that's a podcast I
would very much be interested yeah doing
yeah Alec Baldwin yeah every day
something he [ __ ] takes it well
though he's no no not the [ __ ] we're
gonna do this [ __ ] will go to them I
mean we're gonna get deep deep deep in
his psychological mind
[Music]
well you seems like a nice guy I don't
know but if you look I just imagine you
add his coffee shop every day for a year
like just bugging like you're in like
his like dry cleaners you gotta let me
come when you do it because I I [ __ ]
wrote for that roast and I have a ton of
Alec Baldwin jokes that didn't get
Baldwin I told it down here before Alec
Baldwin's gotta play in New York
opposite Shia LaBeouf yeah yeah I forget
what happened they got into some sort of
right because yeah I love always a
professional equality would be off-book
right the first [ __ ] day
right Holly Walker shows up he's got a
script and that Charlotte both like time
out what's with the [ __ ] script yeah
I need was well we just getting started
with nothing you gotta be off-book bro
yeah imagine Waltons like [ __ ] you
yeah like you know the [ __ ] mind
you know from now on just make sure
you're on for [ __ ] book yeah you're
professional here so like the next day
he wasn't on book and he was past yeah
Shia LaBeouf started I guess that Monday
taught a master acting class at and why
you
LeBeau showed up and he put up his hand
he asked the question because what do
you tell her actor was not prepared like
that type of [ __ ] Wow he took trolling
to a new [ __ ] level he showed up the
guy that called a producer say what do I
do with this kid we're gonna have to get
smack then the next night he took it
deeper Alec Baldwin gets out of his
house out of his car and he goes up to
the building and they shine a bow with a
script don't forget yeah that's it I
will do [ __ ] to you like I'm into it but
that's like I'm that's like that's like
a mentally ill level of [ __ ] rolling
warfare to show up at somebody's house
would be like you gotta do this don't
break it's almost like he was [ __ ]
poking him until he was poking the bear
there's only one she was definitely
poking the bear only one show well
that's what it means to some people yeah
but yeah he's like I'm a New Yorker you
put ketchup on your hot dog I will get
up and walk away from here right and
then I'll pay a Puerto Rican they're
going instead of your office yeah like
you in New York
you won't even [ __ ] catch up on I do
it in Iowa yeah like I'm old school like
that
I let [ __ ] slide just don't talk to me
you don't even put it on burgers even
though you know even what that ranch at
my table
yeah like only won't if you eat ranch
like listen to the over-the-head series
yeah I missed in my house you see what
happened show up my house in hama so let
me go to your house and let this be
honest and chips and that falafel Brenda
hummus all the miracle let's go chop
chair you know yeah I'm old school so I
get it
I'm old school when I see a light I get
off out of respect don't run the [ __ ]
way right I expect the same respect from
you so if I come to watch you and I'm
following you two nights in a row after
four nights are running the life of
fifteen minutes
yeah I gotta say something to you yeah
Fabia right then we're gonna have to do
get the [ __ ] on right and then I'm gonna
go up there and bust you in the head
with the mic because there's some people
who just but that's a show that's the
only show I would consider doing I would
have to get independent investors
torture love no I wouldn't go after
house
I would do what I was doing in Colorado
in 83 I'd pick a guy tonight [ __ ] him
make his life hell
wait there was a guy when I worked with
the tower restaurant yeah give me the
story behind this well I this is the
first time anybody's on here this
started because I was I just did last
Wednesday I did the one-man show and it
was covering that time of my life right
and I remember starting to write this
I'm going I don't even have time yeah
this is a two-hour storm I got hired at
the tower restaurant as a [ __ ]
dishwasher yeah Tuesday's I knew a guy
from New York and he goes dog how we see
you lifting weights and hit in the back
you want some protein he goes I need a
dishwasher on Tuesdays its prime rib
night uh-huh I'll give you all the
mistakes all right I said okay and it
was like 850 an hour I don't know what
it was yeah really man and there was he
was always really cool to me we could be
shrimping whatever I only work Tuesdays
maybe Fridays I hate job like maybe
Tuesdays and Sundays was like a part was
19
yeah and there was a chef that was just
a scumbag yeah like he'd wear the
[ __ ] hat at the waitstaff and call
wages conscious [ __ ] yeah uh-huh
so many [ __ ] chefs so we would be
some nights I didn't like the guy he was
from somewhere he was from quite
California yeah
but he was very white privileged well he
was very high and mighty
and for some reason because the coke era
everybody kissed his ass at that time in
my life I was playing the kid that
didn't do go
because I was taking down drug dealers
mm-hmm so everyone halt I smoke pot yeah
but I didn't do coke and it was well
known in the parties and I would go
people go it isn't snort yeah I have a
ball in my pocket but they I swear to
God I I lived that double life yeah
for nine months yeah because that was my
intention to rob these guys right but
this guy took a special interest in
because he was just a scumbag right
because I work like I'm gonna enjoy this
one enjoy yeah I started working with
Tuesdays Thursdays and Saturdays yeah
just so I could watch him more here is
scheduled yeah casing him yeah I would
just destroy him this is way before the
ring or anybody ever thought about
putting the cameras yeah I [ __ ] tie
the tool I busted into his house and I
wouldn't steal all the co I would take
some of it just to cause a rift yeah it
was roommate yeah you know the same
little [ __ ] ruffled yeah
this will on form once yeah cuz he was a
skier obvious time you're a coat deal
you can't skate you gotta be watching
his fat I don't know Joey's in the
neighborhood they laid me off from
attrition company for the holidays so I
collected unemployment but the building
neither the snow shoveling Snowmass
Village paid $15 an hour - three or four
hours of snow shopping like the home I
told his name was Joe coffee
I gotta go where you go I gotta go
that's it I would just do it the case
out the drug dealers to see what time
the drug news would leave because they
all lived in the same complex yeah from
my D to H right and I [ __ ] but this
guy was a special case I would steal
ones people he just starts thinking he
has Alzheimer's
oh my god I was [ __ ] with him yeah I
would take a little to coat that he had
was fresh I would cut it yeah I would
take half out and put it in a spot
completely
different than where he had put it you
are like the Chinese water torture of
[ __ ] fest that I would be back with
him afterward with 10 of the people and
I would watch him looking around like
where I put that coat right and I knew
it was amazing
yeah it was my hatred from yeah he was
such a prick to the waitresses and the
Busboys he didn't [ __ ] with me I think
he [ __ ] with me one day and I mouthed
off to him and that was the end of it he
knew I was for a different planet yeah
he's like I'm gonna leave this guy alone
I did something else to him like I did
little things I would steal his skis so
that I would bring them back do you
still want to [ __ ] with drug dealers on
this show or now because you do regular
people know regular people okay you can
just do it the regular people that sing
at the house and now it could be great
because you take any of oysters yeah
that's like a bit that's why we're gonna
have like people sent their friends up
you know I'm like warning radio Joey's
voice came into my house all of a sudden
oh but it wouldn't be my voice because
then you [ __ ] know it's like for me
my mother died yeah I'd be sitting in my
living room and all of sudden like you
know like beats watching people in their
own home yes like them all for that
pillow and it's missing yeah
and then put the basses taken a car you
have a lot of women just wondering if
they were pregnant I just be like I
can't [ __ ] remember anything would
take his car yeah move it to a different
building put the keys back get the
[ __ ] ring I was I was going and I
stole his chef book a book of recipes
strolling through the way this was
ending it was like a three-month torture
chamber yeah yeah I knew that he would
come out at night we would all be
playing darts and he'd always look at
this bag of coke and go what the [ __ ] I
know that him and his roommate we get
into arguments I remember still being in
there with three of
for drug dealers like we gotta figure
out who's robbing us and I'd be sitting
there cold man
it's [ __ ] up isn't it like surprise
didn't move in with him why there was
one kid a camera but what his name was
he was a nice kid I kinda liked but he
was Mankato Minnesota he was really from
Minneapolis he was a good-looking kid
but nobody liked him he was a kind of a
part-time coke fiend yeah so one day
somebody actually said we think at end
of like it could be I was such a dirty
dog up there
it was with uh that's the show I want to
do if I ever get back if they would let
me torture one person but I would it
would be like torture that you've never
seen yeah you'd have to get like the
background info for why they deserve it
you know no like oh I got three people
mind already damaged oh you should get
your own this is like the opposite of
queer I this is like somebody reaches
out to you one of their loved ones is
like hey my husband's a piece of [ __ ] or
like you know my wife's being a being a
real [ __ ] she's like she's dead yeah
she's cheating whatever like anything
and then you get that and they bring
Joey in to [ __ ] with them and change
their [ __ ] lives you know like you
cheat on your wife I'll go to the hotel
room is not gonna run away yeah well
even though I'm watching you yeah I
think the funniest thing I ever did
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Rogen was at war with
what's-his-name the guy yeah by six
months ago a year ago he Alex Jones is
folks oh yeah and about Joe Rogan oh so
I took like a fortune cookie little
piece of paper yeah and I wrote I'm
watching and I put it in Joe Rogan
windshield-wiper at the store play with
your paranoia
yeah like a baby
that's [ __ ] dark could you I would if
they knew that it was coming like I'm
trying to think how we get around this
legally you're gonna send people to
therapy I was like what if it's like a
one of those TV court shows right and
like they can agree like you call them
10 grand or Joey's gonna torture you for
a right my job is to put you either to
make you go to the police
somebody's following yeah yeah that's
the main thing that's beautiful keep
hearing Chinese music you like just put
Chinese music yeah you know we have our
own little personal speaker that we've
already got in there Rick yeah or like
old timey radio that would freak me the
[ __ ] go shopping I know you love all
issues [ __ ] a year they really start
to doubt themselves like season one is
it year the fabric of their reality No
season one would you just be miss places
things around taking this car just see
what happens as they're said people
boxes from Amazon yeah and do the
transaction so they think they actually
did it at what time from the computer so
they call customer service customer
service is like wait a second mr saye we
just spoke to you about an hour ago you
said you wanted to chat with you said
you wanted the wig I didn't one no way
really actually get into their phone so
when they call customer service it's you
or no not you but I hear he's like it's
like some new years ago there was a guy
that I work with that was losing his
mind because he was gone bald right I
had grown up my guy that really went
through today I think about that gun I
think how much he suffered at the age of
19 mm-hmm he went through hell he went
I mean spray-painting his head yeah he
went through the whole thing I think
finally did the shave the hair from my
back and crazy gold on your head
yeah whatever the [ __ ] yeah he was
terrible he looked terrible yeah but in
87 89 when I got released from prison I
got a job selling Mitsubishi's with this
the widest most uptight dude you've met
in your life
mm-hmm well you could tell this guy had
never [ __ ] a woman from behind like
right
doggy stop the old [ __ ] military
position right he looks great young babe
yeah he didn't talk during sex you like
you like it babe yeah but one day he
told us in the meeting right he was you
know it's hard for me to really be a
good salesman because I feel insecurity
because of my male pattern baldness that
was it he was a good salesman
yeah I get like he was a good salesman I
was always banging out with him yeah so
I knew that I had upper hand the only
upper hand I'd have was psychologically
him tortured him about his head yeah so
I put hats on his desk all like a men's
wig replacement whatever yeah hold on
one second my phone that's the best
though did you call me back at this
number and they would have given up but
yeah he would be outside with me and
also the phone was ringing walk in there
no I didn't call you no I don't need no
way and he'd walk outside me what was
that nothing
probably sails off oh my god I would
send them brochures
wigs for less that's the best I my
boyfriend has a tremor like his hand
[ __ ] shakes and I'll just shakes all
day so I'll just record him trying to
eat soup and then just send it to him in
the middle of the day for no reason like
my favorite thing to do why does he have
tremors he hoped them I don't know he's
got her a hereditary tremor he's like
yeah my dad has it I have it I was like
oh I'm gonna have so much fun with this
I asked him I was like hey when you jerk
off do you
- quick cuz you got that a little tremor
gives a little sneaking shape to the
helmet is too quick oh my god so what do
people call you rosebud
they call me rosebud you sent me this I
thought it was like a put on like I'm
like this is some puppy chick I know
it's a they saw you or the hippie chick
I'm like the mother [ __ ] she rosebud I
know they couldn't name either bottle
okay let's get the party started
what's with the rosebud let's go they
call me rosebud they call me Rosie those
are the to know you Rosie yeah I like it
when New Yorkers say it Rosie when a
Midwestern er says it just doesn't sound
the same makes me sound like a different
person but when New Yorkers say Rosie it
feel like that name matches my
personality you know where's your family
at all over the place my mom lives in
Maine my dad lives in DC okay
one sister in Boston one sister in New
York one sister in Chicago and you been
in New York six years I've been in New
York for 13 years
yeah yeah see you just in New York right
this point yeah you want to try it out
here I want to try it yeah I don't know
if I can like I've been out here for the
month so far and it's like I love LA
it's relaxing it's nice to get away from
New York but I I really just like you
you live in New York long enough and
it's like a like Shawshank you know what
I mean you get out and you don't know
how to live it's a it's a lifestyle
there that I don't know you you have
skills that you don't need outside of
New York that nobody values outside of
New York but that you spent a lot of
time cultivating because you lived there
you know like just [ __ ] that I learned
in New York like I know how to walk
around the rat yeah exactly
if a rat you know not that yellow I've
had a rat touch my bare foot all right
that was a real thing that happened to
me in New York nobody [ __ ] helped you
know what was this this was in I was on
what were you a bet for 96 Broadway was
wearing sandals they weren't flip-flops
they were sandals and I remember a
[ __ ] rat ran over my foot
i I I was I was like do I cut it off I
didn't know what the [ __ ] to do I was
like I can't believe this just [ __ ]
happened
I just got like rat AIDS I'm done and
nobody helped no I everyone saw it no
one helped they just it's just an
everyday occurrence yeah
did he ever wore sandals again no never
in my life I haven't worn sandals since
then in a city [ __ ] you yeah now you
know you have to have listen my wife is
talking about you know it's it's it's
we're alone down here we have a
seven-year-old I'm not getting any
younger
mm-hmm you know you sit around [ __ ]
Christmas this place blows around
Christmas well let me ask you something
this place blow why would you want to
move to New York because I wouldn't move
to New York okay
starter so to move back to Jersey all
right you know that's fair all those
guys warrant even follow state do great
yeah about they pick up three nights a
week they come into the city
yeah and the other four they stay the
[ __ ] home and the seller [ __ ] pays
yeah there's a straight train notation
yeah you know she's looking at like
horrid though I could take a bus and I
say these things to you very loosely
because in my whole day I could do it I
mean I don't like driving no hole yeah
this would be yeah I'm living out here
really ruined yeah what I'll enjoy do it
like this weekend the Bakersfield was
spawning the Fresno yeah well no traffic
is fun it's it's a great you know we got
to see the view
California is such a great state we're
just living here and this is really him
one in the north and you drive you know
like I was worried all week that I was
gonna get snowed out of a gang in
California on Friday and Saturday
cuz it was supposed to get Thursday
night it was raining here I'm supposed
to get a heavy snow up in the mountain
yeah and they close the grapevine so if
they closed a great one how would I get
up there so I was already late panicking
like if it does snow up there do we
leave it 11 in the morning so it's just
a three-hour difference right where I
was last week it's known in Calabasas
yeah we had to bring winter gear you
know Californians are very weird yeah if
I like I told my wife and we moved to
Jersey
it's work yeah we gotta get that car big
mercy up at the [ __ ] campus we'll
bring it back and karate and piano and
this listen before we make the move you
better [ __ ] think about it you know I
can't make a move is 60 and woman right
you know so I don't know what I want to
do well right now somewhere along the
line you know you think of all these
places to retire to yeah you know
because there's a low state tax or
whatever but do you really want to live
there you're gonna be happy there yeah
calms down the everyday [ __ ] yeah I've
always loved visiting LA but once I'm
here for a long period of time I start
feeling trapped real quick I start
feeling really trapped like like
everything I don't know at least in New
York like I can get out of my house I
can just go I can go to my spots I can
walk to the cellar from my apartment I
can walk to New York Comedy Club I'm
right around the corner from there I'm
walk to the stand it feels like I can
cheat you know because being able to
walk anywhere in New York especially all
of your places of work it feels like
you're cheating like I don't have to get
on a train you know so there's something
about that life that even though it's
harder it's easier because it's just
what would be the transition for you
what is the bonus for you moving on it
being closer to your manager um manager
reps are all out here you know what else
I know I'd like to I'd like to get back
into acting at some point but it's not
stand-up is like my love that's really
all like are you doing the spots right
that yeah in town yeah yeah good you
love um yeah The Improv Ice House just
reached out to me I'm trying to I'm
trying
kind of like get into the store a little
bit just like I'm hanging out there yeah
and doing those produce shows I love the
store like I love clubs I those are the
places I'm most comfortable there's a
lot of places in LA to do comedy that
aren't clubs but I'm I'm more of a club
comic so that's uh you know that's kind
of it like I Love New York because I can
there's so many clubs and I can just do
the club's every night and they [ __ ]
pay like the seller has paid my rent
I'm so grateful to them they're like I
mean st has been good to me since I got
past there about seven months ago so so
much so that I feel guilty being out
here you know like that stay there it's
it's great you know it's funny one of my
dearest dearest dearest friend is Ari
Shaffir yeah and I was one of the guys
who said New York is the place for you
yeah because every night he was out till
6:00 yeah this is a play on til 6:00
here you'll never go home in New York
right you know I can't I think that
would be 40 in New York now be a
stand-up and well this hour we'll stop
for a slice of pizza on the way home
yeah [ __ ] at the pizza Pauly's split
a Stromboli yeah you know I couldn't
even imagine how great that is
yeah for me now 1:00 in the morning is
like [ __ ] 5:00 in the morning like
I'm already wiped out yeah but that's
the thing is like I'm starting to get to
that age where it's like I'm I'm
thinking about getting married having
kids I want to like you know it's like
I'm so do stand-up what do you want to
combine anything because that's what
happens you can't let us get in the way
now I know now you're on deck you've
worked six years now to get to this
place the kids that's got it well that's
got to take a back burner
yeah compte uses a ratty hand for a
couple more
hey you ain't gotta [ __ ] just eat no
kids here right listen man that it has a
complete dimension yeah it adds a
completely different dimension to your
family life yeah I mean I wouldn't even
if I had a kid right now I wouldn't give
a [ __ ] about comedy that's what would
happen that's my my brain would
completely change I just become a father
I've seen how to do the balance yeah
I've become the balance you know there's
no way I'm going out for six weeks I'm
not saying my kid right that ship sailed
sorry Charlie
yeah I gotta come home but every Sunday
coz I gotta be there for family dinner
at 6:00 right nice and easy tonight we
like a family yeah that's what it's all
about yeah you need that structure as a
stand-up or not you just you're just you
know so but it then it helps you like in
a way like to have a stand about to
stand up to live like Lenny Bruce yeah
you know what that means whatever come
let's come you got pills problem right
let's do it
yeah you got the period let's eat your
[ __ ] I gotta stand up not to have
rules yeah in my world rules were not
gonna abide yeah I did not want to get
up and me you will him have to fight for
the bathroom at 8 in the morning after
he'd take this [ __ ]
then I took the [ __ ] there and now you
gotta get ready for work I didn't want
that rush right my mother didn't have a
day job I'm alone the bar yeah so she
opened it in the daytime but then she
went back home did what she did to 8
o'clock right then she took it over at
night I like that I saw that as a child
I work for her mm-hmm I enjoyed you
should go to met games right you be the
Knick fan she was abandoned so she would
go to every [ __ ] met home game yeah
so as a young young man that was screwed
into my psyche then the day job wasn't
gonna work
right I wanted to really do it I really
wanted to yeah be part of a team and all
that [ __ ] yeah go to business meeting
not a joiner
[ __ ] you right and what you make that
decision either there's limited you
could work on the way a house at night
yeah a bar so my options yeah
you know this is all you ended up with
stand-up you you had options yeah the
acting they were for you both
yeah I mean I've never wanted any kind
of structure I don't like structure but
I do I do know that it's good for me
like my brain chemistry responds well to
it but everything else in me is just
like no like I I've never bought a plane
ticket more than a week in advance ever
like I don't do it
you know I don't people who like plan
trips and stuff like I'm my boyfriend
now he like loves to plan [ __ ] and I'm
like I can't do it I don't know what's
gonna work yeah why are we talking about
April right
it's [ __ ] Jackie that we still go
home for Christmas that is like my
biggest price start getting questions
about Christmas and Thanksgiving in
August I'm like I cannot I don't even I
might not even know you guys by then I
don't know what's gonna happen nothing
irritates me more life then I I do for
the road I get my plane tickets we're
out of time yeah I get four since I know
for City I want to go too right if I'm
find JetBlue mint I want that single out
yeah sorry I'll book it now for December
yeah whop you yeah I'm going in that
solo Cabot's right yeah but there's been
a Southwest you the book you know who
gives a [ __ ] right before there's all
those little trips like yeah here's the
thing with stand-up I don't have
structure in my life but I do yeah
because yeah someplace to be and every
time every night yeah and I I did that
once you know for me it was 95 I knew
that hey I had to be out every night
mm-hmm
every night yeah your friend's party
sorry yeah your mom's graduation sorry
yeah that's the mind spill yeah your leg
hurts you got a lot right your [ __ ]
hurts you got to go out or something
squeaking out of your toe sorry you
don't go out yeah you know you had a
right and you had to be part of a cliff
though it was just things I knew that
would look like I didn't watch TV mmm
you see Seinfeld no really yeah no I'm
literally
I'm trying to do swarmed up every night
sports I didn't know [ __ ] sports yeah
I didn't watch television from 1991 to
2003 when I had auditions for NYPD Blue
yeah I was the first time I didn't even
know what I want baby [ __ ] blue was I
didn't know nothing yeah it's amazing
when you become a stand-up and you
dedicate you so tell me to stand up if
you bought it for me it was the weight
gain hmm for me I ballooned up to 400
pounds because I didn't I was that much
understand yeah like you know what [ __ ]
the [ __ ] gym from now so I could see
that's the love that you got for it yeah
it's eating your eyes yeah when you told
you at that six-year level forget it
yeah yeah so he won't eat your [ __ ] not
right now no I can't tell you how many
times I've [ __ ] it's so hard to cuz I
spent the better part of this year
single for the first time as a comic
that is a [ __ ] nightmare as a female
comic dating like a civilian isn't it's
impossible it's not even it's not even
in the cards like it's because they
either want they either love what you do
so much that it they feel like a fan
or they think they can do it better and
they don't know how to deal with you
being funnier than them or like the fact
that you can they say something to you
and you're like you can hit them right
back like so much harder than they were
expecting you know that it it was a
dynamic that I just immediately it'll
dry you right up like being out to
dinner with a guy in a suit who has a
regular life I I tried to like it and I
couldn't oh yeah it's the only thing
that works it's a go for now for now
yeah yeah but I guess you might feel a
little differently like I don't want to
come home and talk about [ __ ] comedy
yeah it's nice cuz I don't he's he's
good like we're both sober there's like
more than just comedy that we have so
it's and it doesn't feel like we only
talk about comedy which is nice
feel like we kind of rarely do but
because I've dated comics I know the
drill and I'm like I don't want to talk
about comedy with our clothes off
don't ever [ __ ] bring up a club name
while we're in bed you know naming my
kid Oh gross
you know rosebud you always got a place
here for the podcast where's the website
it's rosebud Baker calm and all I
announce a lot of show dates and podcast
updates and [ __ ] on instagram so follow
me on instagram at rosebud baker and
twitter at rosebud baker you're [ __ ]
great I like that I like how you
adjusted to the city and I bow out
respectful comics I know that I know the
grind yes you know the grind on
somebody's going through you know how
serious they are about something how
much it's it's very entertaining you
entertain me I wanna watch some of your
stuff at night thanks
so when I was I'm not a bitter old man
by no means about Tommy a very grateful
and thankful I'm here but it it reminded
me of a time in my life when this was
still fun so I had to deal with agency
managers and you know CBS want you to do
this so you can't say that joking yeah
you know it was just a free time right
it's like some of the best times of your
life you know when you're going through
them right now and I just want to
congratulate you and thank you so there
it aired yes yes I'm not working because
you came in and Meyer came in so I've
had a couple of ringers
yeah yeah that's good yeah yeah yeah so
why Ellen all right so this is good that
Bill's doing this yeah Godley so how
many minutes they give you uh they give
me about eight yeah yeah yeah huh
they beep you you kept know they had to
cut one joke that I do it's a joke about
the word [ __ ] but you know what I
was in the middle of doing it yeah and I
turned to the cameras while I was on
stage and said police don't put that on
TV
so like
it was in the middle of the taping and I
just had a panic attack and turns and
was like guys don't and then went on
with my set but this so they cut that
out
but um yeah the rest of it was pretty
happy with yeah I'm happy that things
are going your favor
thank you say hello at the store oh well
you know it's a process I got anything
else but I think you got it so good New
York please come out here for your
little yeah will they call those people
that leave the [ __ ] East Coast to go
to Florida in the will bird oh yeah yes
no bird yeah I'd love to tell you come
back for pilot season but there's no
pilot seasons gonna put out all year
long yeah yeah you're always welcome on
the show any date you want to promote
that yeah February 4th I'm gonna be a
dynasty typewriter here in LA at 8
o'clock so I'll be doing an hour oh [ __ ]
yeah that'll be fun and then [ __ ] my
podcast drops March 3rd but you can
subscribe to it on Monday tomorrow its
devil's advocate at rosebud or with
rosebud Baker and it's on all things
comedy sorry I can't [ __ ] plug [ __ ]
anyway
this Saturday night this so couple
tickets left second show Tabernacle
Athena Atlanta and then [ __ ] well so
I got something I'll see you I enjoy
that so oh [ __ ] first off
narcos February 13 oh [ __ ] I knew I had
some special tie your [ __ ]
hands started shaking
also be at the Tempe improv the 13th
Valentine's Day and the 15th listen guys
you really want to turn your wife on
come see me around tonight then Phoenix
I have a [ __ ] licking in that sack
and drinking juju juice [ __ ] the
chocolate you go a little deep anyway I
want to thank my boogie down AG I want
to thank CBD line I want to thank
rosebud bacon but most importantly I
want to thank you [ __ ] for
working on us the closing song is I want
to be around by Tony Bennett playing on
your own all right we can't do this [ __ ]
they're gonna throw us under the [ __ ]
Jail what do you want from me so right
now put on [ __ ] Tony Bennett it's
Monday and we'll see you [ __ ]
bright and early the Wednesday at
Thursday morning we haven't decided yet
have a great day stay black thank you
very much well on Spotify Thank You Rosa